[Music]
before the creation of humanity the
Greek gods won a great battle against a
race of giants called the Titans most
Titans were destroyed or driven to the
eternal hell of Tartarus but the Titan
Prometheus whose name means foresight
persuaded his brother Epimetheus to
fight with him on the side of the gods
as thanks zeus entrusted the brothers
with the task of creating all living
things Epimetheus was to distribute the
gifts of the gods among the creatures to
some he gave flight to others the
ability to move through water or race
through grass he gave the beasts
glittering scales soft fur and sharp
claws meanwhile Prometheus shaped the
first humans out of mud he formed them
in the image of the gods but Zeus
decreed they were to remain mortal and
worship the inhabitants of Mount Olympus
from below
Zeus deemed humans subservient creatures
vulnerable to the elements and dependent
on the gods for protection however
Prometheus envisioned his crude
creations with a greater purpose so when
Zeus asked him to decide how sacrifices
would be made the wily Prometheus
planned a trick that would give humans
some advantage he killed a bull and
divided it into two parts to present to
Zeus on one side he concealed the
succulent flesh and skin under the
unappealing belly of the animal on the
other he hid the bones under a thick
layer of fat when Zeus chose the
seemingly best portion for himself he
was outraged at Prometheus's deception
fuming zeus forbade the use of fire on
earth whether to cook meat or for any
other purpose but Prometheus refused to
see his creations denied this resource
and so he scaled Mount Olympus to steal
fire from the workshop of Hephaestus and
Athena he hid the flames in a hollow
fennel stalk and brought it safely down
to the people this gave them the power
to harness nature for their own benefit
and ultimately dominate the natural
order with fire humans could care for
themselves with food and warmth but they
could also Forge weapons and wage war
Prometheus's flames acted as a catalyst
for the rapid progression of
civilization when Zeus looks down at
this scene he realized what had happened
prometheus had once again wounded his
pride and subverted his authority
furious Zeus imposed a brutal punishment
Prometheus was to be chained to a cliff
for eternity each day he would be
visited by a vulture who would tear out
his liver and each night his liver would
grow back to be attacked again in the
morning
although Prometheus remained in
perpetual agony he never expressed
regret at his act of rebellion his
resilience in the face of oppression
made him a beloved figure in mythology
he was also celebrated for his
mischievous and inquisitive spirit and
for the knowledge Progress and power he
brought to human hands he's also a
recurring figure in art and literature
in Percy Bysshe Shelley's lyrical drama
Prometheus Unbound the author imagines
Prometheus as a romantic hero who
escapes and continues to spread empathy
and knowledge of his protagonist Shelley
wrote Prometheus is the type of the
highest perfection of moral and
intellectual nature impelled by the
purest and the truest motives to the
best and noblest ends his wife Mary
envisaged prometheus as a more
cautionary figure and subtitled her
novel Frankenstein the
modern prometheus this suggests the
damage of corrupting the natural order
and remains relevant to the ethical
questions surrounding Science and
Technology today as hero rebel or
trickster prometheus remains a symbol of
our capacity to capture the powers of
nature and ultimately he reminds us of
the potential of individual acts to
ignite the world ted-ed
is a non-profit if you value our work
please consider supporting it on
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]